mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour les incendies vous vous en
doutez sont aujourd'hui encore à la
première page de ce journal
la situation cependant s'est améliorée
ce matin dans les départements du var et
des bouches du rhône à l'heure actuelle
le feu persiste uniquement dans la
région de vidauban et partout ailleurs
les foyers d'incendié sont maîtrisés ou
en voie de régression
l'inquiétude cependant reste de mise car
la météo a prévu pour la fin de la
matinée voire le début de l'après-midi
une reprise possible du vent sur le plan
judiciaire monsieur ernest beaux lots
qui est détenu à la prison de draguignan
se défend toujours d'être un incendiaire
il ne comprend pas les accusations qui
ont été portées contre lui
c'est dit il une monstrueuse erreur
judiciaire et monsieur boulot vous le
savez sans doute a décidé pour protester
de faire la grève de la faim toujours
est il qu'en provence et sur la côte
d'azur on commence à y voir un peu plus
clair avec françois corner les premiers
bilans de ces trois jours d' incendies
de forêt en provence en l'espace de 48
heures les incendies de forêt qui se
sont déclarés mercredi après midi dans
le sud de la france et en corse ont fait
autant de dégâts que ceux de toute
l'année passée heureusement avec
l'amélioration des conditions
atmosphériques quoi qu'il faille rester
prudent sur cette information
la météo redoute en effet une nageait
réapparition du mistral
les quatre principaux foyers se dresse
près de nice du massif des maures dans
le même secteur des environs de
marseille et ceux de corse semble à
cette heure-ci pratiquement circonscrit
une reprise du vent malheureusement
risquerait de tout remettre en question
il reste encore de nombreux foyers
secondaires que combattent les
sauveteurs il est difficile de dresser
encore le bilan de ces catastrophes 20
mille hectares pour l'instant de corée
ravagé des dizaines d'habitations
détruites
un mort et trois blessés la parole est
maintenant à la justice pour essayer de
déterminer les causes de ce sinistre
une véritable hantise de l'incendiaire
s'installe dans les départements
sinistrés et on peut le comprendre
le pyromane de fréjus surpris alors
qu'il venait d'allumer trois feux dans
la ville est un mystique membres d'une
secte religieuse qui a déclaré avoir agi
jaune site pour purifier la ville de
toutes les souillures fait laisse les
âmes noires il a été conduit comme vous
vous en doutez à l'hôpital psychiatrique
une dépêche de dernière minute elles
viennent tombé il ya moins de 30
secondes nous apprend que dans le var
dans la région comprise entre sainte
maxime et plan de la tour
le feu s'est à nouveau manifestée par
contre une autre dépêche toujours de
dernière minute elles viennent tomber il
était 13 heures une minute nous apprend
bonne nouvelle cette fois que tous les
incendies qui depuis 48 heures ravageait
la région comprise entre martigues et
sainte mitre les remparts étaient
considérés comme définitivement est un
donc reprise du feu vous voyez avec le
vent dans le var par contre dans la
région de marseille
tout semble terminée il ya également des
incendies bien sûr en provence mais
aussi du mauvais temps en montagne et
vous allez le voir avec michel cause
dans le reportage qui va suivre
puisqu'il n'aura pas fallu moins de
trois jours et de 3 nuits pour ramener à
chamonix
un alpiniste japonais de 25 ans monsieur
yokohama que vous voyez sur cette photo
accidenté dans le massif du mont blanc
alors qu'il escaladait la pointe des
droites
un reportage de michel causse où une
nouvelle fois il aura fallu que dans les
plus mauvaises conditions l'immense le
machine humaine du secours en montagne
se met en branle les elle a atteint une
fois de plus son but et yoko marc
katchou shito est sauvé
hier à 17 heures après six jours passés
dans la neige il était transporté à
l'hôpital de chamonix où son état de
santé satisfaisant
et pourtant il aura fallu pour le hisser
dans un hélicoptère que six hommes
attachés à un treuil le récupère sur une
pente de glace difficile à atteindre
et ceci avec énormément de risques du
reste l'un des guides claude jacquot
explique
la procédure à michel cause quelques
instants avant de procéder au sauvetage
les principales difficultés je pense
seront seront le froid d'une part qui
est assez vif en ce moment avec chamonix
et la neige qui est tombée en abondance
depuis deux jours et qui peut atteindre
une hauteur de 50 centimètres à 1 mètre
je ne sais pas exactement et il peut
nous donner beaucoup de mal
à poser les installations de secours
c'est-à-dire les cards le fixe les
cordes fixes normalement on peut
travailler sur du rocher mais là tout
sera couverte de neige à ça risque de
donner beaucoup de mal
si le mauvais temps arrive nous avons
prévu de pouvoir faire un big wet lareau
espérons pouvoir remonter le blessé
jusqu'au sommet des droites dans la dans
l'après midi
mais si le mauvais temps les
hélicoptères si le mauvais temps arrive
les et clope terre ne pourront pas
monter à ce moment là nous serons forcé
de bivouaquer sur place c'est très
embêtant pour le blessé qui a passé déjà
plusieurs nuits d'or et qui doit être
très éprouvé
donc si vous avez l'intention de passer
le week-end à la montagne de faire des
escalades vous le voyez soyez très prude
à l'étranger les regards se tournent
aujourd'hui encore vers la
grande-bretagne paralysé depuis la fin
de la semaine par la grève et 47000 doc
l'état d'urgence est entré en vigueur
depuis minuit mais l'armée
n'interviendra certainement pas avant
lundi car pour le gouvernement de
monsieur vis en effet le recours à la
troupe ne doit se faire
ce sont les propres mots de monsieur lis
que si cela est absolument nécessaire
de leur côté les dockers par la voix de
monsieur jones le secrétaire général du
syndicat des transports ont fait savoir
que si les troupes britanniques entre en
action dans les ports britanniques et
bien la grève des dockers pourrait
s'étendre aux camionneurs aux pilotes de
remorqueurs et à d'autres catégories de
travailleurs
conséquence immédiate de cette grève les
prix ont augmenté notamment les fruits
les légumes et la viande
conséquence également à l'étranger
puisque les dockers de rotterdam et
d'amsterdam ont fait savoir à leurs
confrères britanniques qu'il ne
déchargerait pas les cargaisons pour la
grande bretagne un conflit donc qui
risquent d'être longs un conflit à
suivre et désire soir à londres
on parlait même de deuxième bataille
d'angleterre au moyen-orient on étudie
ce matin le texte du communiqué publié
hier au terme du voyage en urss du
président nasser ce communiqué soviéto
égyptien est généralement considéré
comme un texte d'attentes
ce qui sous-entend à plus ou moins brève
échéance un plan de paix comme soviéto
égyptiens qui sera en fait une réponse
au plan de paix américain de monsieur
road gers pour le département d'état
américain ce communiqué n'apporte rien
de nouveau c'est la déclaration
officielle mais il mérite ajoutant
washington une étude très approfondie
autre prise de position du département
d'état américain mais cette fois
vis-à-vis des affaires européennes
puisque le porte parole du gouvernement
américain monsieur bart a déclaré à
l'issue des conversations qui se sont
déroulés entre le secrétaire d'état
américain monsieur rogers et le ministre
ouest allemand des affaires étrangères
monsieur walter schels que le
gouvernement américains approuvaient
officiellement les efforts de la
république fédérale allemande en vue de
normaliser ses relations avec les pays
de l'est au cambodge les temples
d'angkor sont à nouveau menacée puisque
la ville d' 6ème rap qui commande
l'accès au temple ville depuis quelques
jours sous la menace d'une attaque
imminente des viet congs aider nord
vietnamiens en argentine des milliers de
personnes ont défilé la nuit dernière
devant le cercueil du général aranburu
enlevé le 29 mai dernier et dont le
cadavre avait été retrouvé jeudi dans
une ferme à 600 km de buenos aires les
obsèques de l'ancien président de la
république argentine auront lieu cet
après-midi et le gouvernement du général
livingstone a décidé une journée de
deuil national en italie reggio de
calabre a connu pour la quatrième nuit
consécutive des violences entre forces
de l'ordre et manifestants qui entendent
protester je vous le rappelle contre la
désignation de catanzaro comme capitale
régionale de la calade
c'est également dans une atmosphère
tendue avec beaucoup de chahut que s'est
terminé hier soir vous allez le voir
avec daniel estève l'assemblée mondiale
de la jeunesse aux nations unies
au cours de cette assemblée qui vient de
cg du 7 au 18 juillet aux nations unies
plus de 600 jeunes de tous pays ont
confronté leurs opinions sur les grands
problèmes contemporains et cela ne s'est
pas toujours déroulée dans le calme
comme en témoigne la séance de mercredi
dernier le représentant du gouvernement
révolutionnaire en exil de l'angola
vient d'être accusé par celui de
l'algérie d'être je cite à la solde de
lisbonne les deux hommes en viennent
rapidement aux mains avant d'être
séparés par les membres du service
d'heure
tandis que le président tente rétablir
le calme le délégué angolais et c'est
vainement de prendre la parole au milieu
du vacarme créé par les autres délégués
finalement le service d'ordre expulsera
le représentant révolutionnaire afrique
et c'est dans un chahut semblables que
s'est déroulée hier la séance de clôture
de l'assemblée dont les participants ont
souhaité pouvoir se réunir maintenant
tous les deux
baby
et tout cela paraît il était observé par
tous les diplomates en poste aux nations
unies je vous propose maintenant de nous
replonger dans l'ambiance du 14 juillet
pour voir avec maurice werther comment
se sont déroulés très loin d'ici à pékin
très exactement au siège de l'ambassade
de france s'est faite du 14 juillet
auquel assistaient monsieur andré béton
pékin place de tiananmen place de la
porte de la paix céleste
c'est un jour comme les autres pour les
chinois une très chaude journée d'été le
14 juillet qui commémore un événement
révolutionnaire mais pas fête nationale
au pays de la révolution culturelle
mais cette année à la réception
traditionnelle de l'ambassade de france
un événement monsieur chennai en
personne le premier ministre de la
république populaire de chine vient
assister à la fête
la raison la présence à pékin en visite
officielle de monsieur bettencourt
ministre du plan ou venez de voir
c'était aussi la première visite
officielle d'un renvoi en procès depuis
l'établissement des relations
diplomatiques en 1964 monsieur manach
ambassadeur de france se félicite de la
venue d'autres de marque comme monsieur
li siagne un vice premier ministre et le
vice président de l'assemblée nationale
chinoise
monsieur homogène
les discours y compris celui du vice
ministre des affaires étrangères de
chine
monsieur locaux il faut s'en suivit vous
allez le voir deux souriantes à gap
monsieur twinlight semble apprécier le
champagne
et les officiels chinois les petits
fours français ce 14 juillet à pékin et
la venue de monsieur bettencourt sont
pleins d'enseignements
d'abord c'est un signe du dégel de la
politique extérieure de la chine qui
était presque totalement inactive depuis
le début de la révolution culturelle en
ensuite la chine apprécie beaucoup les
positions prises par la france à propos
d'un certain nombre de problèmes
internationaux
le vietnam par exemple la participation
indispensable de la chine au règlement
de toutes les deux tous les problèmes
daisy est aussi le pour la position
prise par la france à propos de la
représentation de machines ou nationaux
et même curieusement la chine apprécie
les positions prises par la france et
ses initiatives en vue de l'unification
de l'europe de l'ouest
non pas que le marché commun par exemple
soit en odeur de sainteté à pékin bien
loin de là mais après tout ce qu'ils les
chinois
tout ce qui peut renforcer l'europe de
l'ouest et faire contrepoids à l'urss
tout cela est bonne chose merci morice
werther en france l'actualité politique
est calme f
exception faite peut-être des premières
réactions enregistrées après la
diffusion hier vous l'avez peut-être vu
au cours de panoramas de l'interview de
monsieur tillon qui vient d'être exclu
de sa cellule et qui avait été écarté de
la direction du parti il y a dix huit
ans en 1950 d'ailleurs revoyant
d'ensemble si vous le voulez bien cet
extrait de panorama où monsieur fillon
parle de son exclusion
ces vacances ont commencé pour vous par
une décision politique
vous venez d'être exclu du parti
communiste avec ce en présence cela
s'est passé commun à vous venez me
rappeler des misères
alors regardez comme la bretagne est
belle comment ça s'est passé et je ne
peux pas ici vous raconter les
péripéties au bout desquels quelques
jeunes étudiants de l'ufc qui dirige ma
cellule en obéissant aux ordres qu'ils
ont reçus de mme exclure définitivement
du parti nous sommes ici dans le pays de
l'amener et quand on le lui exclu de son
église les jésuites disait le malheureux
il a oublié son catéchisme et bien sans
doute que beaucoup de communistes en
dirons autant de mois mais il ne s'agit
pas de catéchisme
j'avais demandé à ma cellule que l'on
prévienne la direction qui ordonne que
j'exigeais pour discuter avec le parti
sur ce qu'on me reproche aujourd'hui
d'être pour l'organisation d'un nouveau
secours rouge de participer à un meeting
contre la répression et cetera
j'avais demandé que l'on recommence mon
procès de 1952
or on m'a refusé de recommencer ce
procès alors
et quand j'allais à l'école les cours
d'instruction civique mme apprenait que
quand la constitution et violet
l'insurrection est un droit et bien la
constitution du parti et violé en ce qui
me concerne puisque je demande qu'on
respecte la règle la légalité la
démocratie et on me prouve
vérité dans le parti communiste il n'y a
d'autre démocratie que celle de l'est
sont heureuses réaction donc ce matin
dans l'humanité sous le titre
panorama l'invité de la dernière minute
le parti communiste précise dans cet
article qu'à l'heure actuelle ni la
section ni la fédération ni à plus forte
raison le comité central ont été saisis
d'une quelconque demande d'exclusion il
faut préciser qu'une exclusion pour le
parti communiste est effective à partir
du moment où le comité central l'a raté
deuxième information française de la
matinée cette fois d'ordre économique
puisque l'électricité et le gaz vont
augmenter à partir du 20 juillet le prix
de vente de l'électricité haute tension
sera majoré de 3 5% et celui du gaz de
5%
quant à l'électricité basse tension
c'est l'électricité ménagères si vous
voulez son augmentation n'est pas encore
précisée sans doute dans le courant de
la fin de la semaine
nous changeons de sujet à présent
puisque avec rosie morel nous allons
parler de quelque chose qui est paru au
journal officiel hier je crois c'est le
certificat de santé alors aux immoral ce
certificat de santé
qu est ce que c est pourquoi un
certificat de santé il faut expliquer
qu'il ne s'agit pas si vous voulez de
carnet de santé comment dont nos enfants
par exemple ils sont en nourrit sur le
quart marc systématiquement les maladies
d'enfants les dindes et vaccination etc
c'est un certificat de santé orientés
dans un sens très précis qu'est celui de
la prévision et de la prévention des
maladies qui font des handicapés moteurs
sensoriels ou bien manteau c'est à dire
des débiles profonds ou moyens bon je
voudrais qu'on vient justement sur ces
deux termes nous avait dit prévoir et
prévenir alors prévoir je crois aussi
vous avez quelques chiffres donnés mais
oui il faut prévoir parce que à l'heure
actuelle
malheureusement les besoins dans le
domaine du traitement de la rééducation
des handicapés mentaux ou moteurs ou
sensoriels sont loin d'être couverts
on en compte un million cinq cent mille
en france et sur ce nombre il n'y en a
pas un car qui peuvent bénéficier des
soins de rééducation j'ai dit prévention
aussi parce que plutôt ces maladies sont
dépistés et plus on a de chance de
redonner à l'enfant un équilibre normal
mais je voudrais insister sur un point
c'est que il ne s'agit pas si vous
voulez de l'innovation la loi dès 1945
prévoit qu'un enfant soit présenté tous
les mois pendant la première année tous
les deux mois pendant la seconde tous
les six mois jusqu'à 6 ans un centre de
protection maternelle et infantile houle
et examiner gratuitement ou bien chez
son médecin et dans ce cas il est
remboursé mais les parents ne le font
pas et on a été obligé au fond
d'assortir d'une sanction qui est que
les parents qui ne leur ont pas qui ne
leur ont pas présenté au moins deux fois
à des dates qui restent à déterminer
dans les décrets d'application ne
toucheront pas les allocations
familiales voilà merci rosie morin
michel drucker les sports il y à eut
foncé états unis il ya eu ensuite
allemagne etats unis ce sont maintenant
les athlètes français qui se retrouvent
ensemble pour les championnats qu'il y
en ait fait des événements sportifs
importants
ce week-end les cheveux en quatre ans
d'athlétisme et le tour de france je
vais commencer par le tour de france il
arrive demain à paris vous le savez
merckx remportera ce tour de france à
sens unique
aujourd'hui c'est la dernière étape en
ligne une des plus longues tour versa et
235 kilomètres
jean-michel le lieu nous a téléphoné il
ya quelques instants pour nous dire que
le peloton roulait très tranquillement à
30 à l'heure on peut donc s'attendre à
une arrivée au sprint à versailles ce
soir aussi vrai d'ailleurs les derniers
kilomètres de cette étape
second événement vous l'avez dit jean
pierre guittard les championnats de
france d'athlétisme ils ont commencé
hier soir à colombes il se poursuivent
aujourd'hui et demain sur ce stade de
colombes pour vous mettre dans
l'ambiance je vous propose d'écouter
claude milieu qui nous parle des
premières épreuves qui ont eu lieu hier
soir les épreuves féminines trois
finales effectivement michel drucker
vous remarquerez qu'il y à un couloir
libre mademoiselle pas nous ça préféré
courir les séries mais reste est
qualifié pour le saut en longueur et
c'est madame chez bell qui va gagner en
13 secondes 7/10 un dixième du record de
france de mademoiselle k you do
noël laval 14 mai andré 14 heures au
lancement du javelot demoiselle bordés
gagne avec 46 m 66 et 50 centimètres
d'avancé sur madmoizelle lambert 46
mètres 16 nouveaux records de france
cadets au saut en longueur premier
record de france par odette du cac si m
47 elle améliore de 8 cm son précédent
record
voici odette du cac au ralenti sa série
6 mètres 47,6 m 36 00 6 mai de 21 et six
mètres 18 du cac nouvelle vedette de
l'athlétisme féminin les autres épreuves
de la soirée d'hier se sont présentés en
différé dans un peu plus d'une heure à
14h30 sur la première chaîne puis à
16h40 en direct cette fois raymond
marcillac l'aude milieu et pierre
sabbagh vous feront vivre les épreuves
de la journée sport automobile sur le
circuit de brands hatch en
grande-bretagne débute dans quelques
heures le grand prix de formule 1 de
grande-bretagne
l'autrichien rinne qui est actuellement
en tête vous le savez du championnat du
monde des conducteurs a réussi le
meilleur temps hier aux essais il est le
grand favori de cette épreuve que vous
verrez avec stéphane collaro aux
environs de 15 heures 40 sur la deuxième
chaîne et une heure plus tard toujours
sur cette deuxième chaîne jacques perron
vous commentera une des épreuves du
championnat du monde deux hors bords qui
se déroule à cajarc dans le lot
voilà si vous aimez le sport je pense
que vous serez comblé la télévision vous
offre de nombreux programmes cet après
midi athlétisme et cyclistes sur la
première chaîne automobile et
motonautisme sur la deuxième vous avez
de quoi je pense passer un bon après
midi devant votre poste de télévision
merci michel à la page de spectacles de
ce journal vous savez le monde du
spectacle et hendaye avec la mort de
luis mariano et les obsèques de luis
mariano se sont déroulées ce matin en
l'église d'arcangues le petit village du
pays basque où le chanteur avait une
propriété hier matin et vous le voyez
sur cette photo un dernier hommage avait
été rendu à luis mariano
dans la cour de l'hôpital de la
salpêtrière hôpital de la salpétrière où
il est mort dans la nuit de mardi à
mercredi france vérité nous ne quittons
pas le spectacle puisque je crois que
nous allons parler maintenant du
festival d'avignon
effectivement
première semaine du festival d'avignon
s'achève après early mornings d'edouard
bande de diable et le bon dieu de jean
paul sartre présenté par le tnp aussi
une création d'une compagnie la
compagnie jacques dumais une pièce un
peu ésotérique dont nous parlent
maintenant
claude d'agde au cloître des carmes
jacques 10 mai présente les incantations
une tragédie satirique adapté de
gaspillage de danilo dolci c'est
l'occasion pour cette jeune compagnie de
s'essayer avec talent à plusieurs formes
d'expression théâtrale cette oeuvre nous
conte l'histoire de la sicile rester
moyen-âgeuse coincé dans la gangue de
son passé de ses superstitions de sa
résignation
le problème posé ses c'est cet
accouchement
impossible de la sicile cet accouchement
du monde nouveau cela se termine sur une
phrase de marx il ne s'agit plus comme
un tel monde mais de le transformer
seulement cet accouchement ne se fait
pas sur la scène bien nous avons été
surpris que nous sommes descendus en
sicile parce que nous avions l'idée
traditionnelle de la mafia gangsters de
chicago vous croyez moi quelque chose
dans ce genre
non c'est tout simplement une
une classe dominante en sicile qui
défend ses intérêts et qui représente
même pour grande partie post it une
certaine protection
c'est un phénomène proprement sicilien
par rapport à l'extérieur par rapport à
tout ce qui vient de l'en dehors c'est
sicilien mais c'était tout bas que sur
le nom et ce faute idée jamais je venais
le nord chaussures les eaux ils
poussèrent des cris effroyables voyant
je leur dis n'ayez pas peur c'est noir
et le vent tombe à n'ayez pas peur c'est
moi une n'avait rien compris quand leur
esprit était boucher jean vilar me
disait il ya quelques temps en parlant
de votre spectacle
ce stand in line hockey il donnerait
l'occasion aux gens de se rendre compte
que les pays en voie de développement
sont à au fin fond certains continents
mais à quelques centaines de kilomètres
d'avignon
oui oui et même peut-être plus proche
que cela mais en voyant là la sicile les
choses sont plus claires pour nous on
pourrait peut-être faire quelque chose
en france mais on n'aurait pas le même
regard et il est intéressant à réflexion
par rapport à la sicile de voir à quel
point nous sommes proches mais aussi de
ce genre de conduite
jusque là tant ceux parmi vous et vous
supporte veulent
quelques images souriantes pour terminer
ce journal quelles sont les nouveautés
en matière de lingerie hillis la mine où
les révèle sur des images de philippe
simon images qui ont inspiré quelques
réflexions amicel toulouse la mod 70 61
ans semble laisser perplexe la statue
dont le déshabiller date un peu
une nuisette en dentelle blanche et
satin rose qui ne nuire à personne
des combinaisons dont on aimerait bien
percer le secret
un peignoir en voile de coton qui peut
faire souffler un vent de folie chez
vous messieurs
ça ira ça ira même très bien pour cette
révolutionner en chemise de nuit de
coton blanc et charlotte
gageons que si les têtes ne tomberont
pas elles se tourneront
aux yeux
et
you love game & watch est très bonne
lordon pembe aux aliments pour votre
pied-à-terre une chemise de nuit courte
et déshabiller
alors
un déshabillé habillé en lamé turquoise
et
non
laissez-vous impressionné comme ce
photographe par nadège déshabiller en
tergal verre d'eau
3 tenue de tests pour recevoir au saut
du lit
mesdames si vous portez gentiane alibaba
et mirabel ces trois tenues nous
viendrons vous rendre visite les bras
chargés de croissance
cela
pas d'autres nouvelles jantes y at il
pas d'autres nouvelles de dernière
minute si ce n'est que ce petit sujet
pourrait faire aussi la fin de telles et
nuit en souhaitant une très bonne nuit
bien sûr aux dames qui portaient ces
charmantes combiné en tout cas nous vous
souhaitons à tous un très bon week end
au revoir
et